jetzt ist es natürlich so dass viele
menschen denkt na ja kommen die
schauspielerinnen die spielt im tatort
mit die verdient doch millionen
irgendwie was zur seite gelegt haben
ja wir haben hier eine gute
einschaltquote im tatort meist wegen des
golf million zuschauer sage ich mal so
groß wie haus und dann sag ich mit jan
josef immer wenn jeder uns einen euro
geben würde das versuche ich steckte er
die immer ein und sagt mir du hast
nämlich mal in einem interview gesagt
dass wenn du auch nur zehn prozent von
ihm bequemste eigentlich happy wie läuft
mit den verhandlungen
die sind natürlich unter den tisch
gefallen die behandlung die verhandlung
aber nie aber was denn eigentlich für
einen tatort über 100000 tat glaube ja
ich will jetzt vielleicht schreibt er
mir gleich christine du bist ein idiot
aber es mit inhalt also der krieg schon
so viel krieg nicht dass du nicht so
viel kristall sowas ja das ist natürlich
noch mal so eine mann-frau geschichte
auch in unserer branche dass die
gehälter noch längst nicht angeglichen
sind er ist ja es geht um erfolg und
gute verhandlungen um das man das in den
verhandlungen sich auch so erlauben kann
er so wahnsinnig erfolgreich sind
ich weiß nicht da müsste ich auf die
barrikaden gehen
[Musik]